I certainly like that place where people don't go so much, but maybe there aren't many
places where there aren't many people in the middle of the night.
Sometimes it looks like you're just a little off the beaten track so that no one has been there, so in the
extreme, you can be a
tens of thousands of visporo vics baths everywhere in
your daily life.  But I'm very interested in the nature of the third child,
for
example, the
various things that appear in front of me when I'm walking alone, and how I am.
Since I was a kid, there was a cheer about whether I was moving in it,
so nature for me was so-
called will. Rather than nature, it's more
like the outside world,
so nature.  And science is two high 2s. It's not such a concept, but
science is something that everyone has. In other
words, it's more of a sense to understand the world,
and
that world is so-called.  It's nature, so there's science as a direction to understand nature,
which isn't which, isn't it? Then what was
before was something outside of us and beyond humans
?  As a publicity to understand,
we have a scientific way of thinking. Now that we have a
ritualistic cross section,
we have been in a situation since March 2011, so after
all
there is no prefectural police. The
power of nature is too great.
I thought I was doing something little by little to understand it, but I didn't
feel like it was broken.
Tako I know the experience of losing almost everything today, so it's
a little psychologically
until then
3 It seems that people were acting against nature.
I was feeling like that, but now
I feel like I want to do it for a while now.
The reason is
that the value of that photograph is changing,
that is, the way of looking at the history of photography will change drastically
from now on.
So the way to enjoy it may be different from what it is now, but it's
just that a
wonderful artist will be born at any time.